twenty-two-year-old singer-songwriter
front chesco Yeats who opened for Hedley
on their 2016 hello world tour broke his
silence earlier teroz on the sexual
assault allegations against frontman
jacob ho guard and while the ho guard
still denies any non-consensual sexual
behavior it was on that now notorious
tour where many of those are larmy
accusations came to light I want to ask
you about the the time you were on tour
with Headley because so many of these
stories and the allegations around
Headley were on that tour I actually
couldn't believe it yeah and you know I
actually could not believe it when I
heard about it it was weird because for
me most of the time I was too tired to
really socialize with anyone right now I
would go back to my bus and I would
think nothing of it but I kind of it's
just weird to see all of this happen the
way that it's happening yeah you know
what I mean it's it's pretty dark but
with me I never really hung around that
thing I never hung around any of them
you know so but we knew they were wild
we knew they loved being rock stars
right but it's still shocking to hear
that things went this far
yeah well there's a difference between
being a rock star and what this is sure
and it's just you know when I saw it
even pop up on my phone didn't put me in
a good place you know that means right
even now when it comes to just meet and
greets that you will do are there are
people aware are you now more aware of
just how the interactions you know
should happen so things don't get you
know misconstrued or you know even
hugging a fan people are you know taking
that into consideration and stuff like
that I think people are pretty good at
telling what your intentions are sure
you know what I mean so I don't have to
really be careful about anything okay
because my intentions are never skewed
that way right
[Music]
the Toronto Board musician is now
opening for Justin Timberlake after JT
followed and supported his career from
start you guys have had a connection you
and Timberlake for a while when it comes
to your music how did that happen well
he was always kind of you know it good
to me in a way where he was kind of
watching my career develop like he did -
he tweeted about call when it first came
out yeah and you know now now I'm here
on the man of the woods - it
the tour is a chance for him to show off
his new music including the
caribbean-inspired single come over
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
every year my family would go to the
Caribbean almost every year and just
late at night a little five-year-old
Francesca without this hair right would
be walking around as a kid just tripping
out man I was like I said I was a
strange kid yeah yeah